ladies and gentlemen thank you so much
for coming tonight to our third
shortlist screening to support the EE
rising star Awards my name is Chris
Mandal I mean the features editor at
shortlist and I'm joined by Florence
Pugh thank you so much for joining us
tonight and amazing to see this film
again can you tell us a bit about first
of all how you approached Katherine as a
character and what you knew about her
life before she got married because it
as it starts we see her kind of get
married off and doomed to this life with
this horrible family but what do you
know about her life before then so I
think it is worth saying that when when
we filmed Lady Macbeth I feel like I'm
quite quite am i quiet I can you hear me
oh good
when we filmed then at birth there was a
scene beforehand where where she was
seen with with the child on a beach and
she was supposed to be kind of like a
tutor to this family and when when she
was sold with the piece of land she was
sold to to those lovely men that she
then didn't - so that's that we did
actually film those scenes but when they
came to edit it they realized that they
actually were will thought that it was
better that we meet her when she meets
the rest of that household and we meet
her when she's down the aisle she's
about to say I do and it's all a little
bit too late to turn around and at the
time I was quite upset about that
because I quite liked obviously we see
Katherine in in a particular state all
the way through the film and I quite
liked seeing a little bit of warmth and
and kind of tenderness to her before
before she started killing everyone and
and I was a little bit bummed out about
that and and will then obviously said
well if we're gonna follow Catherine's
story then let's follow her when she's
as scared and and as I suppose
interested as she is so I got that but
where I think Katherine is before hand I
don't I never ever went when when
reading it or filming it I never felt
that she was a villain I I never thought
that she was a monster I think that she
always acted in in a particular way
because of the circumstances that she
was put in and and I don't I still today
don't think that she's a bad person or a
nasty person I think she does awful
things so where I like to think she
started before the film was as any 16
year old girl was at that time I think
she's just caught up in something very
particular and she starts mothering
children very specific yeah and it is
about it's about one woman trying to
survive isn't it in this really
difficult situation just to use
everything that she has to hand because
so much is taken away from her young age
what was it like filming then tell us a
bit about where you filmed that and and
and the estate that you were on because
it's not the incredible place yes we
film just outside of Durham we'll
actually the director William Eldred he
went to university there and he knew
that area well and he knew how he wanted
to set lady macbeth out and where we
filmed was this the state and it was
actually the Earl of Durham's estate
well was once and this entire grounds
was this well this amazing house that
was no one was living in no one was
using and it was completely empty and it
still had some of well obviously all the
architect on the inside the design was
still as it was and this this this
estate was once a Victorian Zoo one of
the first zoos so actually the reason
why it closed down it wasn't made for
that but it ended up becoming the reason
why this Zoo closed down was because too
many of the chimpanzees kept on running
onto the main road which I thought was
quite amazing so they have all these
drawings of these like you know lions
and monkeys and actually where I get
married
in the church was the lizard Hut or the
lizard house where they kept all the
lizards and snakes and the cold blooded
animals but yeah Wow
I know but yeah that's where we filmed
in for filming wise we only really had
one location so production office was
set up there and usually when you're
filming you always lose days in amongst
the shoot to travel because you have to
travel the entire cast and crew and
location to wherever you're going but
because we had one location it meant
that we could really set up camp there
and actually it really worked her favor
because some days if a scene wasn't
working or something wasn't happening we
just move upstairs and go shoot
something so yeah and tell me a bit
about how you like transformed into
Catherine because watching the scene
where her course it gets put on it I
mean that made my ribs hurt just
watching it so what was it like with the
way that she is made up and then how did
that help you become her I people have
always asked me how I prepared for
Catherine and I I didn't in a funny way
I didn't ever feel like Catherine was
calculated I always thought that she was
instinctive and so I thought well I'm
never ever ever gonna know how it feels
to shoot a horse or how to smother a
child so there was no point in me in me
guessing because I think that's the
worst thing to do so I tried to trust
myself and tell myself that will there
is no preparation for that I can't force
myself to put on a performance because I
have no idea how it feels to try and to
bury a horse so lots of those scenes I
tried to not really think about and I
and I try to live in them when I was
doing it not in a horrible way but in a
way where I didn't really want to have
that in my head so lots of my
preparation was completely down to the
costume and down to the course
and when I first had my my costume
fitting Holi Waddington who was the
costume designer put me in a corset and
was putting on all these original
garments on me and I was quite excited
about corsets cuz I as a kid I always
wanted to either go into clothes or go
into acting or performing so I was
always excited about materials and how
things worked and I was like yeah I'm
gonna be in a corset this is amazing and
I've always thought the courts corsets
would Rick they are really beautiful
they're a work of art and I remember
asking Holly all these questions about
this corset and she was putting me in it
and um I'm just realizing that it was a
different type of breath and about an
hour into my fitting I got these awful
back pains really really awful and they
made a corset for me so it was for my
body and it was obviously made of kind
of modern give so that I wasn't you know
strapped in with whale bones which is
what they were originally made from but
I I started realizing that you are
completely caged in your clothes
especially in in all the big dresses and
and all the big crinoline that was the
point and I noticed that when you're in
those corsets and when you're in those
dresses if you eat you use breathing
space to fill your stomach with food so
you end up becoming silenced and I would
only realize this when I was doing it
and it's so it's so interesting because
when women go on about wearing corsets
it is completely true you cannot breathe
and if you are to do anything you have
to have someone to go to the loo with
you let alone like help you bend over
and put your shoes on so I just found
that fascinating and if I knew that I
didn't like wearing the corset then you
can sure bet that Catherine hated
wearing the dresses so we started
putting that into the script we started
making sure that whenever Catherine was
in a corset she wasn't as free she
wasn't as creative and whenever the boys
leave home she's always either in a
nightie in a dressing gown or she's
naked
and being happy as Larry and eating I
wanted her to be eating when when she
wasn't in a corset so that played a
massive part in my preparation because
it does it affects absolutely everything
you walk differently you you talk I'm
one of the things I really like about
Katherine is that even from the start
she's quite defiant to the people that
are effectively like imprisoned her and
even when you laughing at your husband I
just found that so different to the way
that in especially in period films that
women are often beaten down and it's so
miserable but there is this like spark
and have from the start I think that she
do you think she knows then that she
wants to kind of find a way out or is it
something that only happens when she
meets Sebastien I don't think she's ever
planned it I think things happen because
they do but one thing that I always
loved and I even remember when I was
reading it was how how confident she was
for letting everybody know how she feels
and I think a that's very rare for a
woman in a period film and be that's
very rare to actually watch a woman be
unapologetic I suppose I die I don't
really see that too often an early now
that I'm really seeing a lot of it but
it was so special when reading it
knowing that it was set in 1865 that she
just didn't give a toss and if she
wanted sex she was gonna go find sex and
if she wanted to drink alcohol she was
gonna go drink the entire salad worth
and if she wanted you know company she
would find it and that laughs that you
said you know that was something I don't
know she's constantly playing she's
constantly pushing the boundaries
she knows that Anna comes in every
morning and opens the curtains and if
she's gonna see the dressing gown on the
floor I mean there's gonna mean one
thing and one thing only she's bored
she's completely bored and she's playing
with someone that she she knows she can
play with yeah
and I think that's where her naivety and
hurt
childish nurse comes into it is that
she's just she's left left in the house
with nothing to do something really
interesting there because I wanted to in
the next question was going to be about
Anna
even though Katherine sex and Sanders it
awful just doesn't seem to have a lot of
empathy for Anna who's in a similar and
worse position in a lot of ways I wanted
to ask you just a bit about the
Katherine Anne's relationship and what
your thoughts were on that and and
whether you were surprised she didn't
maybe be a bit more empathetic towards
her totally and this was something that
we being Naomi we all well we all went
up Cosmo Naomi and I and and every most
of the crew when I'm week and a half two
weeks before we started shoot and that
time was dedicated towards wills but
anytime with us and chat about
characters and something that that me
and Naomi couldn't quite get our heads
around was why why did why they don't
just buddy up and like both kill the man
and both run away together because
that's what you would kind of like there
would be a great film exactly and I
think what we came down to was that I we
we thought that that Katherine felt
maybe betrayed because part of the scene
previous which you guys didn't see sorry
was they're on their way to the church
it's about ten second scene they're on
their way to the church and Katherine
asks Anna what's he like and Anna says
yeah you're gonna be happy and she says
yeah but what's what's he like
essentially and and and Naomi Anna says
he's over he's a respectable man and so
then Katherine smiles and she runs off
to the church now obviously that that it
plays anyway without that but what we
felt happened was somewhere along the
line
Katherine felt like Anna had helped her
get there and Anna hadn't helped her
stop where she was going and Katherine
being as stubborn and as childish as she
were she she couldn't let go of that
grudge
and even though that's absolutely
pathetic
there has to be something said for the
fact that when Catherine goes in and
finds Ana being bullied
she gets her down yes she's horrible to
her later but she gets her down and she
frees her but still even though she's
been kind to her she has to then call
her a pig like so I do think there is
this funny like she won't let people be
awful to her but she can't actually find
it in herself to forgive this woman that
essentially helped her be be caged and
there is also something in the fact that
if you look at the two women Catherine
despite the fact that she has power she
has no freedom Ana does and I can go
outside and I can have conversations and
I can go have a life even though she's
working in the house she can still be
free and so all those times where you
watch Catherine looking out the window
and looking at Ana that's where that
came from
in in me and how I tried to judge that
was there despite the fact that there's
clearly different titles weirdly Ana has
more freedom than Catherine does and
that really really yes to Catherine so
that's where it kind of leaned from but
yeah there is a kind of there's been
lots of questions about why they didn't
just buddy up and become yahya
sisterhood but that's where we kind of
came from and and and I feel like for
Catherine to grow she kind of has to
yeah I suppose you can imagine her not
trusting her like what's to stop her
alternate Lea turning her in or like
because she'll have been in in that
situation for so long yeah but she's
conditioned to just you know yeah I
thought that was a really interesting
point and also one thing that is quite
interesting is the relationship between
her husband and his father there's a
very interesting sort of toxic
relationship between them because he
even seems to ask his dad permission to
leave in the one of the dinner parties
at the start that's really interesting
yeah I mean part of where Catherine's
behavior comes from is from copying the
men so
when the men are gone and she goes into
the stables and she says face the wall
she learnt that from her husband telling
her to face a wall when he tried to like
it's all really weird behavior that son
has learned from dad Katherine's learned
from son and it's all this kind of like
childish learned behavior thing and
their relationship between father and
son is awful as well so when he dies and
and he says I shall place my two feet on
his grave in the morning they don't like
each other's thanks dad but also you
yeah you tell them to stop laughing
which is exactly what your husband
sister Katherine I thought was very
interesting how they kind of borrow that
one of the scenes I really wanted to ask
you about is the scene when you shoot
the horse because I thought that horse
was such an amazing performer tremendous
acting from the horse he was my favorite
actor to work with ever when I so it was
actually wills birthday when we we
filmed me getting married in the morning
and then me shooting the horse later on
in the afternoon and when we came to it
the the horse trainer came up to me and
he goes all right okay um so the horse
has three girls and he'll do a warrant
he'll do it twice he'll do with rice and
then that's it what you mean he was like
okay so first girl will pay you like you
know give it a go second time you got a
set third time it's kind of a kiss the
second time doesn't work but after the
third time guy doesn't really know you
know horse doesn't really know that and
that is not working anymore right what
do you mean he was that basically horse
knows when it's working and when it's
not working I was like wow this is
amazing great contract and we kind of
like went on and and I was I was told
where you know I needed to do the gun
and all this Mellark and then I walked
on and as I walked on I shot the horse
and as I shot the horse literally in
time this horse lept up and squealed
jumped
screamed whinnies landed on the floor
wriggled around as I shot it and this
happened I screamed because I thought
I'd shot the horse and then I've been
like and then they said will goes cut
cut cut Florence you need to carry on
with the scene I was like I think I saw
those no he's just reacting this horse
was so fantastic that I actually thought
I'd shot this home and so this really
was that okay so that was your first gun
girl you got to my god crap jump for it
amazingly they trained this horse with
this these like they recognize what
you're doing and the horse is also
linked up to a lead and depending on
what the guy does like with these tugs
and poles and all this stuff the horse
will then perform but the horse knows
that he'll have three goes and then
that's it so we did it and it was the
most amazing scene because I just had to
react this this horse I didn't have to
rely on lines or someone you know doing
their spin on something this horse was
absolutely fantastic so that is why it
was my favorite scene just because it
was totally real and horrible really
horrible this horse was screaming and I
went to go and shoot it again oh my god
so yeah that's why it was my favorite
also so unlike anything I've ever done
yeah it was okay with you after when you
stopped filming with the best bit was
like afterwards when I have to bury the
horse the guy okay so you don't you
don't yeah he was like right okay so now
now you're doing the bury and I was like
yeah he was like okay come in in between
the two horses legs and it was like
right go [ __ ] you left I was like yeah
co-op it to your left
yeah go back to your left yeah it was
like right there go yeah he was like
he'll kick you in the face okay and he
goes you go any further he'll smack here
when is he gonna smack when he goes well
basically if I triggered him this horse
would try and get up and as he got up he
would just clobber me in the face
so while I'm burying that horse I'm in
she like so yeah brilliant they say you
shouldn't work with animals but that
sounds like one of the things I really
loved about especially re watching the
film is that sometimes you can't really
tell what's actually going on in
Catherine's head especially the more the
film goes on and I wanted to ask you
about one of the scenes we talked about
this briefly
we interviewed Florence for the magazine
and Florence talked with this great
story about scene in the film and it was
so good but it was such a massive
spoiler that we were like we can't put
it in the magazine so I really want to
ask you in front of these people tell me
about the the big lie that she tells and
and how that scene came together so I'm
gonna do it backstory quickly um Teddy
Teddy and Catherine I I always believed
that catherine was really shocked and
and slightly it's her only bit in the
film where she's maternal I don't think
she is maternal but I think it's the
only bit in the film where she is and
and and something to know is the fact
that teddy is the only person that ever
compliments her even though she's had
this entire relationship with Sebastian
with her husband with her father-in-law
with Anna no one is ever actually nice
to her other than Teddy Teddy says that
she's beautiful and so the way that I
wanted to play that happen was that she
for the first time was actually
receiving some kindness which is rare
and so when she ends up killing the
child I always believed that that was a
I mean obviously it's a difficult thing
to do but I always felt that that was
realizing that her survival if she
thought about it was gonna have to come
before the kid otherwise the kid was
gonna get the house and her life and her
money and she would be out on the
streets before she knew it
so that last scene when Sebastian comes
in and says we killed the kid and she
says and that boy that boy was like a
child to me I never read that as
anything other than the truth but when I
did that I always found it broke my
voice because the thought of her loving
something and then having to not loving
but caring for something and then having
to kill it because she had to survive
before the child was always quite like
whoa that's like nothing I've ever seen
before
and then when we first watched it in
front of an audience that scene comes on
and I'm watching it and I say in that
child that child was like that that I
was like and that boy was like a child
to me I'm watching it and everyone
starts laughing am i what are you
talking about it's not funny
it kept on happening people kept on
laughing and people kept on saying all
that laughs at the end do you really
think that I mean that light at the end
did you really think about it and I
still do this day which is funny cuz
obviously maybe my head's too much in it
but I then probably think that's the
biggest lie in the film because she
means it when she says it
and how disturbing is that that she
means it yeah she's talking about the
child and uses it she's like so
manipulative she uses it in that moment
she's allowed to show a little bit of
like you know sadness but only when it
suits her right yeah the first time I
saw it I took it at face value and I was
like wow we finally seen this sort of
scrap of humanity in her after all this
stuff she's gone through and then you
were like yeah that's not actually true
she made it and I never watched it this
time and I was like oh my god I don't
think she just made it up I think she
genuinely felt that but she she gave it
a slight window yeah yeah and then
everyone told me that that was like oh
yeah cathodes really good at pretending
isn't she is like okay and we haven't
talked about Sebastia Merc so tell me a
bit about what it was like working with
Cosmo and you're kind of interacting
together
so working with Kazi was fantastic and
when we auditioned Shaheen Paik casted
it and when we edition dwee did three
chemistry reads with three guys and one
of the the notes that we'll started
giving off way through the day was like
I want you guys to wrestle so the aim of
the game was he would try and push me
and I would try and push him and whoever
fell over first one and then we had to
play the scene from there and there were
so many amazing actors that day that
were really really beautiful and had you
know a wonderful presence but cause he
was the only one where me and I we both
of us we just fought each other and that
was the key of Sebastian and Katharine
was this like push and pull this tug
this fight and and actually it it was so
easy to do any of the the naked sex
scenes with him any of the fighting
scenes with him because we just didn't
care it was like if I elbowed him in the
groin it wasn't a thing and if he kind
of accidentally hit me in the chest it
wasn't a thing it was just that was the
nature of Katharine and Sebastian was to
be borderline aggressive whilst showing
their kind of attraction to one another
and he was was so is usually so awkward
to do any sex scenes but for some reason
it was just super super easy and there
was no weirdness or funniness it was
just like yeah cool guess cuz the
characters feel like they're on the same
page in a lot of ways that must really
help when you're actually working
together and the film's been out for
it's been quite a long time since the
film came out and I had such an amazing
reception and I wanted to ask you why do
you think the film and Katharine
specifically have like resonated so well
with people I think because it's unlike
things that we've seen I think she is
very I've said this so many times but I
really believe it I think she's a very
modern woman in 1865 and that's rare I
think we're very used to seeing a period
drama where it sticks inside kind of the
norm and it doesn't it doesn't stick
inside the
when we actually see this woman want
things and not only want things but she
goes out and gets them when she she's
not allowed them and weirdly that's
quite rare yeah and I think lots have
been lots of people have been attracted
by that lots of people have been
repulsed by that and I equally love that
too there's been so many q a's where
people have just shouted abuse at the
fact that Catherine is awful I'm like
yeah great give me more and then there's
lots of people that want to you know
thank Alice for this character and I
just think it's um it's not usual that
we that we find a woman like this as
young as she is to react the way that
she does and people have responded to
that which is great and I love talking
about it so good and what does it mean
for you then given what you just said to
be nominated for the amazing it's a bit
of a weird one my parents have been
arguing over who gets the three plus one
so I've been like guys calm down it's
not worth the divorce where is mental I
think when we made this film it was so
tiny and it was such a small family and
it was made for such a small amount of
money that I never ever ever thought
that it was going to make it this far
not because I didn't believe in it but
because it's just it's not expected and
when we were making it there was such a
feel of like everybody mucking in and if
that chair needs to be moved and someone
quickly moved in which is so odd for
film usually or TV anything and there
was such a special feel because everyone
was invested because of the storyline
it's it's we weren't all paid made major
major checks we were all kind of aware
that this was because we all wanted to
do it so when we worked on it everyone
was putting their everything a hundred
and fifty percent there was no no one
that didn't want to be there and so to
see this film now go so far is amazing
and every time it's gone to a new
festival or a new award or a new
ceremony or a new whatever it's it's
really lovely to see
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]